i think what the league needs they're
talking about a playoff bubble
and i tweeted about this on sunday
morning i feel like i figured this out
for the league i know you want a bubble
for 32 teams now i don't find that to be
logistically feasible
especially not just well what do you
need
they need time because
what's going to happen is they're going
to be there only so many
ways that they're going to be able to
configure
the schedule there's only so many times
you're going to be able to move
somebody's bye week
at the last minute teams might need
multiple bye weeks
teams may have multiple outbreaks
postponements
or cancellations so here's what i would
look at you keep
look at you keeping your own stats here
did you tell them
hey you know bring up my tweet bring up
my tweet
ah damn let me read let me read this
cause i'm reading let me know i'm
reading it tweet
please read my read it in my voice read
it in my voice
i don't know if i can do that i don't
know
i won't be offended i won't be offended
i don't know if i care
i can't go that deep man i can't go that
dude i got a high voice i have no idea
what raymond james stadium's event
schedule is but maybe the move for the
nfl is to play the postseason in the
spring that's a good idea
perhaps host the afc and nfc playoffs in
two cities
with two bubbles let's talk about the
schedule puzzle
and finish on time that's what michael
smith would do
right so you got roger goodell do i do a
lot of air quotes
i do a lot of airflow time i do do a lot
of air cools i know i'm sorry it's kind
of like i usually wear i'd eat a lot too
so i had a i had a i had a follower say
hey nothing going on at raymond james
until may 1st
okay that's what you say so there you go
if the nfl is going to do this thing new
week to week come on put my tweet back
up i got to read my tweet
you know i said some others gotta be
michael smith bring that back up oh here
we go thank you
uh they're gonna need more than another
week or two i say give yourself a couple
of months
no reason they couldn't start planning
for conference bubbles
and a spring postseason starting right
now seriously
see oh man and then good night and then
that's a good idea look
look look look at this oh there you go
look at it you can see this you usually
can't see right
nfl discussing postseason bubble in los
angeles and dallas sources that's the
athletic
you're welcome yeah you're all welcome
okay so
i'm saying do the bubbles for the
postseason it's much more feasible to do
with seven teams each and you see what i
wrote there but but finally but you need
more weeks
you need more weeks one extra week a
week 18 to me is not gonna cut it at
this rate maybe it will
maybe they get lucky but five weeks in i
think they need more flexibility the
season ends in january anyway
give yourself more flexibility on the
back end of the season
hell maybe even give yourself some point
in the middle of the season to
to take a break there may come a point
because here's the thing michael there's
something people forget
for all the protocols in place okay
um and jason we're gonna start the show
with this i didn't even know you just
but i can't believe we didn't record the
show with this is such a good idea
wow jason not that you're not capable of
having good ideas i'm just like
this is really good jason mccourty was
like
like michael jackson he was like they
don't really care about us like he was
like nobody cares about us blah blah
blah
when a lot of the players the players
wanted to do this
it was actually a surprisingly low
number of players
that opted out the players decided that
they wanted to play
and the protocols are not to prevent
contraction
but to mitigate the spread but the
problem is michael as we talked about
is they don't live in bubbles and i'm
not talking about a bubble that the
league sets up
i'm talking about kovac cases around the
country are rising
so i just find it hard to believe that
this season is going to go off
is the air quotes normally good
i think we might see a situation we
might see a situation michael where
there needs to be a restart
but it may need a league wide by the
middle of the season just to get their
act together
so give yourself january maybe even
february
set up your bubble move everything you
know move the playoff teams there
and play your postseason you know in the
spring and every time about a spring
season anyway why not play the
postseason in the spring
free of charge free consultation this is
why yeah well i don't know why it's free
of charge you should have charged
somebody get a little extra money off of
this man you got kids come on you got
kids man they didn't even
you know always they eat they eat they
got to go to school come on come on you
got
clothes they're always growing they just
grow these kids
um but really think about this i'm glad
you're like
i'm glad you dig it i i think it's a
great idea the nba
season through no fault of its own
i mean stops in march because of the
pandemic and we just talked about the
nba finals being completed what month is
this
october so it can be done
the season started almost a year ago
michael that is incredible
the season started in october
the end the 2019-20 season
started in october and it ended in
october
and we don't care we're still arguing
we're still having like the same
arguments we had pre-pandemic
jordan versus lebron it doesn't matter
so if you love the sport enough i'm on
your side with this if you love the
sport enough
you do have to build in just be ready
to take some pauses to take some breaks
to get that thing done
i believe in a bubble and i know you
don't think 32 bubbles is feasible
it is it's not convenient
it can happen it's just not convenient
okay think about this most teams
most teams have some type of setup
where they can have they can create
their own little village
within a training camp it's called
training oh yeah
but like we saw it yeah there are a lot
there are a lot of like
la la and they're and they're new
they're beautiful new stadium
so far many things around that there's
so many things around that you got
hotels you got
restaurants you can just kind of
rope that off so to speak and say okay
this is this is
this is going to be our world until our
season ends
players won't like it i know they won't
like it but
it almost ensures that your season will
and you can control your environment
and that's what you can't do unless you
have a bubble if you you don't have a
bubble
season is probably not going to be
completed let's just face it you're
going to have to get there
where it is the postseason is gonna be
critical because
you can't you can't have people
compromise in the playoffs it's one
thing to be like okay this guy is out
for this game or we're gonna
postpone you know this game for this
week i mean your options are so
limited and your margin for error is so
slim come the playoffs and so
you know and i was reading the athletic
article you know they don't want
according to sources that's the main
thing is they don't want to have
player availability compromise in the
postseason
and not have flexibility and get they
all talked about it it's like you know
you talked about 18th week today i
believe
and it's been being kicked around
flexibility is key
and and they they just need more time
you know that's that's
you need to buy themselves more time and
can i address this this jason mccourty
thing
all right jason mccordy jason mccourty
is right
no the nfl doesn't care is he yeah yeah
he is he is
he's he's right but this is why it's so
confusing
he's right the nfl doesn't care about
him doesn't care about his brother devin
probably doesn't care like not
personally the nfl's that
doesn't care about anybody personally
but that's not the point
the point is they care about you
as a business this is a whole business
this is a transactional relationship
is it's not relational it's not
relational in a
uh intimate sense it's relational in a
transactional sense
and that's why i don't understand why
the nfl seem to be
so unprepared for what we're dealing
with right now keep in mind
pandemic hits in march roger goodell
holds the draft conducts the draft from
his basement
in april or may whatever it was maybe it
was may
their season doesn't start until
september you got all this time to
figure it out
and now they're coming up with new
protocols now
they're telling coaches we're going to
find you if you don't wear your mask why
don't you make
like why didn't you mention that months
ago you seem to be surprised that all
this is happening
hello pandemic we're in month seven okay
the rest of us are in month
seven hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports